I’m going to start this episode by bumming
you out: everybody dies eventually.
Even if you manage to avoid bear attacks or
grievous bodily harm, something in your own
body will go wrong sooner or later.
Usually later though, since age is the single
biggest risk factor for disease.
Strangely, we don’t really understand why
our bodies deteriorate as we age, and so we
don’t know how to prevent it.
But there are a few scientists who think they
know how to stop the relentless march of time,
and they figured it out by accident.
The researchers in question were studying
why some cells in our bodies become cancerous.
They believed turning off a gene called BubR1
could be the culprit, so they genetically
engineered mice with BubR1 deactivated.
But the mice didn’t develop tumors as expected.
Instead they aged rapidly, and by the time
they were just three months old they had thinning
hair and cataracts.
The mice lost weight, developed heart problems,
and died much earlier than normal.
When the scientists examined their bodies,
they noticed that the mice had accumulated
a particular type of cell called “senescent
cells.”
Senescent cells were once healthy normal cells,
but they’ve been damaged or their DNA has
mutated.
To avoid passing that damage onto their daughter
cells, they stop replicating and start putting
out signals for the immune system to come
and clean them up.
They’re not exactly dead, but they’re
not doing anything either.
Unless you count putting those chemical signals
out, which you should because it turns out
they can affect nearby cells and cause inflammation.
If the immune system cleans up these cells,
it's no big deal, but it appears that over
time, the immune system stops responding and
the senescent cells build up.
Some people liken these cells to zombies but
to me they seem more like grumpy retirees.
They’ve done their job at the plant until
they can’t work anymore, so they sit on
their porch yelling and hollering for the
police to come and take them away.
The police come a couple times but eventually
they stop, and soon none of the neighbors
can sleep anymore.
Eventually those neighbors retire too and
they sit on their porch screaming and the
neighborhood becomes a terrible place to live.
The researchers found that when they regularly
removed these cells from normal mice, the
mice stayed healthier and lived 25% longer.
So the researchers think that clearing out
these cells could improve longevity in humans
as well.
But of course, it’s not so simple.
It’s never simple.
First and foremost is the problem that senescent
cells vary from one tissue to another.
There’s no one distinct marker for all of
them that a treatment can target.
So the researchers are working on treatments
that can target multiple markers at once.
But even if you could totally cleanse out
all the senescent cells in your body at once,
you might not want to.
There’s evidence that senescent cells play
a role in helping you recover from injury.
The same researchers that found all these
benefits of removing the cells found that
wounded mice healed slower without them.
So scientists and doctors will have to be
careful how they apply this treatment if it
ever turns out to be effective in humans too.
Aging is something we just can’t escape,
but with continued research maybe one day
we’ll think of old age as a treatable disease
rather than an inevitable fate.
]If you like this video you should subscribe!
We’re friendly, I promise.
We’ve come up with all sorts of kooky ideas
to stop aging, like infusing young blood into
our veins.
Julia covers that, here.
When scientists first discovered senescent
cells in 1961 and suggested it might be aging
on a cellular level, people called them
idiots.
Funny.